why did you choose her I tripped body
camera footage shows the moment a Grand
Rapids police officer fired his weapon
after he says he accidentally tripped
oh my God that was me that was me it
happened on December 9th of last year in
Grand Rapids Michigan when a group of
officers responded to a potential car
theft I pulled I pulled the set of keys
out to make sure they're not to that car
I'm making sure that car's not stolen
Grand Rapids Police say they saw a
vehicle that possibly matched the
description of one that had been stolen
and connected to other crimes they
followed the car and driver Davion Smith
who drove to his father's house and went
inside when Smith came outside officers
had already set up a perimeter police
later learned Smith's vehicle had not
been stolen body camera footage begins
as Smith is handcuffed just moments
after a gunshot rang out
oh my God that was me that was me why
did you choose her I tripped
officer Gregory Bauer says he tripped
and the gun accidentally discharged the
bullet did not hit anyone but was fired
into a building near Smith's Direction
Bauer was charged with a misdemeanor as
prosecutors say he carelessly fired his
weapon causing property damage opening
arguments in Bauer's trial were
presented Thursday September 1st for the
latest developments in this story and
all things True Crime stay with long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie